there have been some major innovations
in the battery technology space that can
fix a multitude of issues with today's
batteries all at the same time way back
in 2020 researchers at mit made a
breakthrough with solid state battery
technology which could allow phones to
last for days without needing a recharge
and the way that it works is by
replacing some of the liquid components
inside today's lithium batteries with
solid ones last year apple filed for a
patent that would allow apple to use
larger batteries in future iphones by
eliminating wasted space and using
anti-swelling technology this is exactly
what mit was talking about with their
solid state battery tech and if apple
were to implement it today it could
literally lead to an iphone 13 pro max
with 72 hour battery life or on the
other hand apple could go back to
creating even thinner iphones kind of
like the thin titanium middle layer we
see in the recent iphone 14 design leaks
but with added features like an always
on display without sacrificing any
battery life